oui c'est une déclaration de joe biden
sur la pelouse de la maison blanche ce
jeudi matin qui relance l'inquiétude
générale dans le dossier ukrainien ici à
washington contrairement aux
déclarations émanant de moscou et
notamment de sergueï lavrov que nous
avons entendu ces derniers jours le chef
de la diplomatie russe les informations
déclassifiées par le pentagone semblent
confirmer la volonté de vladimir poutine
de passer à l'offensive ce sont les mots
des généraux du pentagone selon joe
biden et ses états-majors strictement
aucun retrait de troupes n'a été
observée au contraire un renfort à
hauteur de 7000 hommes et des manoeuvres
d'intoxication de la part des militaires
russes postés devant la frontière
ukrainienne ont bien été observés de
simple déplacement de troupes qui vise
justement à brouiller les observations
américaine ce renseignement
pourtant
dont le pentagone avait été
particulièrement généreux ces derniers
jours et ces dernières semaines joe
biden annonce que les sanctions
économiques promises et brandi depuis
des mois maintenant à l'encontre de
moscou sont prêtes et pourront être
utilisés dès les prochains jours ce sont
ses mots le président américain annonce
qu'il n'a pas eu de réponse assez
concrète de son homologue russe vladimir
poutine à ces dernières demandent de
dialogue mais également qu'il n'a plus
l'intention de solliciter son homologue
en tout cas pas dans un futur proche ni
par écrit ni par téléphone et enfin le
président américain annonce qu anthony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine s'exprimera aujourd'hui et à
sa demande à new york devant les nations
unies il est impossible au moment où
nous parlons d'anticiper sur les
annonces qui seront formulées par le
ministre des affaires étrangères
américain mais si l'on en croit cette
dernière déclaration le climat n'est pas
du tout à la désescalade et et la crise
franchit donc ce jeudi un nouveau cap de
tension merci matthieu mabin depuis
washington